let's let's get into this now
many people in the culture are intensely
focused on rooting out
problematic language and toxic messages
they insist that we must
rename sports teams and objects in outer
space
and and rebrand grocery items and ban
books and censor films all for the sake
of protecting society
from the harm that inappropriate words
and ideas may cause
anyone who steps outside the perceived
lines of decency is condemned with a
hostility that we once reserved only for
rapists and murderers it would be quite
confusing then for any
alien who lands on this planet or any
person who emerges after being lost in
the rainforest for the past five decades
to discover
just what sort of media these
perpetually scandalized damsels in
distress
enjoy because the very same people who
were so traumatized by a fast food ceo's
comments that they boycotted his chicken
restaurant for eight years
and the very same people who have
tearfully denounced offensive disney
costumes worn by children
and the very same people who are liable
to break into convulsions of anger if
you say something really provocative
like
men have penises and the very same
people who invented concepts like
trigger warnings and safe spaces
are the ones who will listen to
appreciate and celebrate
the most vulgar and degrading television
shows films and songs made by some of
the most
loathsome and repulsive people this
country has ever produced
they are puritans about all that is
innocuous and libertines about all that
is
genuinely objectionable they have in a
word
everything backwards and never has that
contrast been clearer than with the
reaction to
the latest bit of audible sewage from
the rapper
cardi b now before we get into the song
we should note that cardi b
a former stripper has admitted publicly
that she used to drug and take advantage
of men
um in her own words in fact listen to
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
a real scholar there that we have on our
hands cardi b cosby's a weak excuse for
this behavior
is that she had to do it to survive yet
she has
elsewhere brag that she made up to three
thousand dollars a night as a stripper
and had thirty five thousand dollars in
singles saved by the time
she turned 22 cc irs for comparison sake
a surgeon earns around 120
an hour which means that cardi b by her
own testimony was taking in
substantially more than a surgeon just
by taking off her clothes
and yet she needed to lure men back to
her hotel room drug them and rob them in
order to stave off starvation
somehow the story doesn't add up it
would seem that she is simply a
sociopath and a predator who enjoys
preying upon
other human beings like bill cosby who
also drugged people and took advantage
of them
but this fact does not seem to have
troubled reebok or pepsi who have both
signed million-dollar endorsements with
the confessed criminal
the cancel culture has ruined people's
lives over edgy tweets they posted as
teenagers
yet cardi b cosby's personal history
involves drugging people and taking
advantage of them and she admits to it
and brags about it and faces absolutely
no consequence for it whatever
white privilege tends to manifest itself
in rather
unexpected ways these days you might say
now
cardi's newest song topping the charts
in the u.s the uk across the world
is called wap it's an acronym that i
can't spell out on the air but
which references female genitalia in
fact i can't repeat any of the lyrics on
the air but suffice it to say that the
song begins and
ends with the refrain there's some
[ __ ] in this house and
everything that happens in between would
seem very much to
uh confirm the those declarations
the song wants to be extraordinarily
vulgar and it succeeds it also wants to
be shocking but in that regard it fails
for an artist to be truly shocking she
must have wit
and intelligence and vision there is a
severe scarcity of those qualities among
any of the people involved in this song
so
they're reduced to being merely
obnoxious instead
the entire song is like something that
someone might have scrawled in red ink
on a bathroom stall in fact i think that
a bathroom stall may have a writing
credit on this song but i can't be sure
the problem is is less with the music
itself
or the video accompanying it than with
the reaction to it
in saner times if women were rolling
around on the floor and screaming about
their genitals for three and a half
minutes
we would just ignore them or perhaps
refer them to a counselor who
specializes
in that particular form of mania but we
don't live insane times and so a song
with a generic beat
mediocre production qualities and
semi-coherent lyrics encouraging women
to make prostitutes of themselves
is celebrated as according to the new
york times or the la times rather
a sex-positive triumph and according to
usa today
an anthem of female fierceness
and it gets even more absurd than that
there's an article on a website called
complex which hails wap as a great
cultural achievement and it just goes
into great detail
talking about about this work it
exclaims in part
[ __ ] is the epitome of female empowerment
both both cardi and megan
the other uh artist use the term loosely
on the track
are powerhouses of female sexuality
independence and dominance in a
male-dominated genre that is often
criticized for misogynistic wordplay
towards women
the two rappers have never shied away
from taking back the narrative of
femininity and hip-hop
and during a time when black women have
taken to social media to advocate for
their protection
and support while basking in their
blackness the music video
couldn't be more timely continues on
later walking in the footsteps of iconic
sex positive female rappers
like trina lil kim and kia kaya
cardi and megan splash around in a pool
of water which we can assure you
which we which we can assume is
symbolism for yup
and describe in detail what a night in
bed with them might be like
uh though through cocky self-assured
lyrics the duo
own their sexuality and shine light on
other prominent sex symbols and female
musicians
and then it continues on later wap is a
prime example of progressive womanhood
and modern femininity
the theme of women prioritizing pleasure
and joy runs from start to finish
liberation and power are showcased in
lyrics placing the track as the duo's
most forward and
compelling expression also the song
slaps
okay many other articles have been
written um
to inform us predictably that any
criticism of this song is misogynistic
and racist and all the other is and isms
and this is the real danger uh there has
always been
stupid degraded vulgarity in the world
but it becomes especially to use the
favorite term of gender studies majors
problematic when the degradation is
presented to our children as something
to
aspire to so that's the issue here
self-debasement is not empowering
and it is rather important that we make
this point even if it does provide the
people who are
recently offended by a can of beans an
opportunity to call someone else a
snowflake for a change
but the difference between this
criticism that i'm making right now and
leftist snowflakery
is that the criticism here is warranted
and the message being criticized
is actually harmful young girls are
being
explicitly encouraged by this song and
by so much else in pop culture
to embrace their own objectification to
offer themselves up to be used by men
who see them as nothing more than a
masturbatory device
they're being told to choose emptiness
over joy and to see stupidity and
crassness as feminine
and the frauds who cheer this on and to
help to and help to
usher a generation of girls into a
miserable life of whorishness and
loneliness
will soon revert back to decrying the
objectification of the female form and
pinning the blame
for that on the patriarchy and other
phantoms
the point here is that even the people
actively promoting the objectification
of women
and the commodification of sexuality
know very well that the
harm that it causes and will tell you
that if you catch them on a day when
they're pretending to care about it
now i want you to consider
uh just to further illustrate this the
words of a woman
by the name of suki hana who appeared in
the wap music video and
later joined cardi and the gang for
discussion promoted and broadcast by
apple music
here's what she had to say listen to
this i feel like
being like sexual [ __ ] like
i don't see not wrong that cuz baby i
got uh
three kids and i mean i got these kids
from
at the end of the day me being a whole
like these people say
like honestly i liberate a lot of a lot
of hoes
you feel me when i hear cardi talk about
popping some
me and my is witty like we that liberate
us because it's like [ __ ] you
self-respect as hoes how y'all got
self-respect
like i don't think y'all got
self-respect like that because first of
all
you supposed to tax these that
self-respect
you feel me like i just it makes me feel
liberated like i love crossing
boundaries
because guess what scare money don't
make no money if you're gonna be scared
to get that money you won't be scared to
be yourself
and say this who i am then you ain't
gonna get that coin like that
thanks leaving aside the the the
fingernails there that must make it
impossible for her to eat a cheeto
without blinding herself
notice the question she poses how y'all
got self-respect she asks
she quite literally doesn't even
understand the concept of self-respect
she goes from recoiling at the very idea
that a woman would respect
herself to suggesting that true
self-respect is to be found in the
payments
a man renders after having sex with you
need i explain the problem here people
pay for goods and services to get paid
for your sexuality is to have it treated
with the same reverence that one affords
a hamburger
or an oil change you have reduced
yourself your body your very person
to a commodity and offered it to someone
who doesn't care about you
certainly doesn't love you and sees you
only as a means to an
end this is the diametric opposite of
self-respect
why do you think drug abuse and suicide
are so common among prostitutes
reducing yourself to the sum total of
your body parts is not a path to a
healthy life or a long one we should
note
it is a road to disappointment and
despair and death
where the fun for whatever it's worth is
sure to dissipate when your physical
beauty wears away
if not long before this is the road that
cardi b her fellow
pop stars and her insidious cheerleaders
in the media would like your daughter to
walk down
and as a man with two daughters
i have no shame or hesitation in saying
to these forces
no and go to hell
i'm sorry that you didn't have a father
who loved you but my daughters do
and so they're gonna know better you can
go wallow
in your own filth and misery all you
want i will make sure
that my girls do not follow you there
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content